[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give you
two beasts advice and begin while the
week's news from both bars and AFC
Wimbledon John how are you doing I'm a
little tired because I've just returned
from London where I was attending an a
of Snipes and match with ten donors to
the project for awesome
all of whom or I I think all of whom
listen to dear Hank and John so thank
you very much it was a lovely lovely 27
hours in London but I am tired and also
I came home at like during daylight
savings time which compounded the
tiredness and also as you know Hank
daylight savings time makes me extremely
angry because it is the stupidest thing
that humans do which is really saying
something and so I'm in a bit of a mood
how are you good
I never really understood how bad
daylight savings time was until I had a
baby I know well it's even worse if you
have a four-year-old who goes to school
and every morning she's just like why
why are we doing this in the dark when I
should be asleep and I'm like I am
completely sympathetic to your issue I
it's Benjamin Franklin take out a
hundred dollar bill and be like this guy
or possibly a fifty I'm not sure I think
it's a hundred aren't they called Benja
Benjamins
yes that is what they're called and that
is for that reason I don't actually know
if it was Benjamin Franklin but I once
heard that it was farmers but I recently
asked a farmer friend of mine and they
were like no we hate it we absolutely
hate daylight savings time it's terrible
it messes everything up especially
because we have to get our kids to
school it's not like farmers don't have
kids uh I would like to hear somebody
make a compelling argument in favor of
daylight savings time it's the stupidest
it just it infuriates me mmm ah now I'm
John I'm close to the breaking point
Hank let's chill it's good to change
traffic do you want to talk about the
the elephant in the room I what mostly I
just want to know what you think the
elephant in the room is right now just
in general at any given moment I'd like
to know which elephant you think is in
the room
you say do you want to talk about the
elephant in the room my first thought
every time is Putin he's listening right
now he wants to know what we think yeah
I mean you're kidding but you're also
not kidding
what is the elephant in a room our
six-hour episode of dear Hank and John
ah yes of course we released a six hour
episode of dear Hank and John which
included one hour of new content and
then five hours of heavily recycled
content I I would apologize but instead
I'm just gonna say you're welcome you
are welcome and so yeah I'm not sure it
seems to have happened differently for
different podcast players we don't know
what the problem was is different
lengths different content we did nothing
different and nothing wrong and we do
not know what happened if you have some
idea what may have happened please let
us know obviously we did something wrong
for the record I I don't see it
happening to a lot of other podcasts but
we are going to try to make it not
happen again and if this episode is six
and a half hours long then maybe we just
need to retire but in the meantime Hank
and I read to you a short bit from a
longer poem okay yes please
so this is a new poem and it's quite
long and we'll put a link to it on the
patreon at patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John you don't have to donate or
anything to see all the content you can
just go there it's a poem by cavae akbar
who's one of my very favorite poets and
he lives in indiana which i think is
just amazing he's so good for the
indiana art scene it's from his poem
forfeiting my mystique and this I think
is just gorgeous I wish I was only as
cruel as the first time I noticed I was
cruel waving my tiny shadow over a pond
to scare the copper minnows
that is good I like that I like it I
like it when they're real short - I know
you do he's here to pay attention I wish
I was only as cruel as the first time I
noticed I was cruel is just so good god
I mean he does that several times in
this poem that level of shock and wonder
and anyway everybody should check out
Cafe Akbar he also has a fantastic
Twitter where he's constantly retweeting
great poems so yeah he's over at at cafe
Akbar that's ka veh a KB a our Hank
should we answer some questions from our
list yes John I think that we should I
think that we should do that and I think
we should do it well and humorously you
did you don't seem ready you seem to be
so ready this dear hey good job my job
involves me staring at the same spot for
hours on end on the chance that
something of interest will happen in
that spot I'm very curious you've made
it very vague but I get it naturally I
find myself getting bored pretty quickly
and I need to keep my mind occupied by
reading books or listen to podcasts
which I am allowed to do and then I get
home and I see my cat lying in the same
spot for hours much of the time awake
doing absolutely nothing and seeming
content with that so I'm curious why do
we need constant mental stimuli -
animals also get bored long live the
king David that is a really interesting
question and one I don't know the answer
to but the first question to examine is
what the heck does David do for a living
I've got two theories okay
one he guards the Mona Lisa like if
you're a regular museum guard you move
from room to room
object to object but if there's if
you're in a museum that has like one
painting that is very very famous that
painting always has like a couple of
guards
so that's theory one David is in the
Mona Lisa
guarding business and then theory - is
that David watches a
curity camera for a living right
potentially watches a security camera
actually my thought was like candy
inspector like like there's a there's a
conveyor belt and there's just candy
bars and you're just making sure that
the candy bars look right but in that
situation would you really be able to
read a book you know no I guess not
I guess not yeah I I just assumed that
reading a book meant listening to one
Mona Lisa guard that's my theory Hank do
animals get bored uh animals definitely
get bored yes and I assume that when
animals are sitting there and they look
like they're just staring off into the
distance and awake and doing nothing
that they are doing what we're doing
when we do that which is thinking about
stuff yeah I think I suspect they're
thinking like you know what I wish I had
a bird that I could eat or like or like
back when I had a bird how could I have
done that better like that one time
actually got one right like I'm just
life it was sort of replaying that which
is sort of like what I do with
conversations except with bird death
yeah when I actually think about my
thoughts like when I pause to consider
what I'm thinking about in any given
moment it's so astonishingly mundane
like almost none of my thoughts are
thoughts that I would be at all
surprised if you told me a cat has yeah
I maybe have one thought that I wouldn't
expect a cat to have per day yeah I I
find it very enjoyable to to be like
okay where am I at now and how did I get
here but and I I think that it must be
similar for animals where they're just
sort of like follow and the train of
thought and but that train of thought
requires stimuli to in order to have
things to think about and so if your cat
had did nothing ever then it would not
have good things to think about and it
would be bored and it would be cruel but
your cat has had things that happen to
that day whether they are you know
considered by you to be of interest and
and it's it's thinking about those
things and what happened last week to or
something I don't know it's just
thinking about stuff differently than we
think doesn't have words and stuff but
it's thinking about stuff yeah and I
think every internal the internal life
is an adventurous one I think that lots
of interesting things happen on the
inside of people's heads and cats oh
yeah you know that great Eudora Welty
quote right of course oh yeah me I know
all the great Eudora Welty quotes a
sheltered life can be a daring life as
well for all serious daring starts from
within ah yes
no it's so good by the way if you ever
want to read a great essay about writing
and reading Eudora Welty's one writer's
beginnings is one of my all-time
favorites so if you're looking for
something to distract you while you're
guarding the Mona Lisa that is
definitely one that I reckon all right
this next question comes from Jed who
writes Dear John and Hank I need some
advice I have a very important guest
coming over soon and I need to clean my
room and in the shortest amount of time
possible however I haven't successfully
cleaned my room in almost five years and
it's very bad my room is small it does
not have a closet in which to hide
things and the walls are plaster so I
cannot burn it down also based on my
limited knowledge of quantum mechanics I
currently both do and do not have a
floor okay it's under there somewhere
Schrodinger's floor my question is what
is your preferred method of cleaning
rooms any dubious advices appreciated
Return of the Jedi
there's so many so many different
schools of thought but I think that it's
nice that you can focus on the one room
first yes but that the first thing you
do a hundred percent absolutely what you
need to do first is go to Target or your
box store of choice and buy containers
that can fit in places in your room like
under your bed containers potentially
like foot of the bed
trunk-like things not you can get these
things fairly inexpensively whether it's
like the plastic like basically gigantic
Tupperware's or like a piece of
furniture that might just look like a
piece of furniture but it's hollow and
you can throw stuff that you don't want
to throw away into them to get a garbage
bag and throw things away I just clean
my office because I have a fancy guest
coming to to my office for an interview
soon and I needed to make this place
look really great and I did it in about
two hours and I did it largely with the
help of a bag of trash bags yeah I think
throwing stuff away is key I just want
to point out though Hank that Jed has
already done the first and most
important part of my strategy for
cleaning rooms which first is to wait
five years right and also before you get
started ask someone who literally cannot
respond to you for at least a week that
is a great strategy as well I clean
rooms very rarely but when I do I clean
them intensely so I first try to get all
of the clothing that is on the floor off
the floor and either into a washing
machine or into the pile that says this
is going to Goodwill or into the pile
that says this is going to be turned
into rags for cleaning projects I will
never actually undergo then the second
thing that I try to do is get all of the
other stuff off of the floor I think
your container suggestion is a good one
but you don't necessary have to go to
the Container Store or anything fancy
you can just put stuff in cardboard
boxes that you mark with you know you
just write down what's in it and then if
you don't open that cardboard box for
like six months that tells you that
you're good to just throw that box away
it doesn't matter what's in it you
haven't needed it for six months you'll
never need it again then the last thing
that I do is vacuum because I'm framing
that you have a carpeted room Jed
although you may not know given how you
don't even know if you have a floor the
thing about vacuuming is that even if a
room is not perfectly clean if it has
those vacuum marks
people think it's clean yeah in fact
don't even turn the vacuum on just like
run the vacuum over the carpet make the
marks right you just need the marks I
think actually you do have to have the
vacuum on for it to really for those
marks to really show but run that vacuum
five minutes before this very special
guest comes over and they're gonna walk
into your room and they're gonna think
oh wow this is a person who values
cleanliness and then eventually over
time you'll disappoint them but they
will think this person respects me and
my authority that's a they've it's like
it's like rolling out the red carpet
except it's just the vacuum lines we
roll out the vacuum lines for you you
know that you are a respected guest
that's right if any of you ever have me
over to your house I expect vacuum lines
everywhere on the walls ha ha ha oh my
gosh Hank I recently was in a house that
had fuzzy walls and I could not get over
it what a brilliant idea carpeted walls
that's the culture god I just feel like
I like I understand carpet I'm
surrounded by right now in my office
it's a it's a it is a good and useful
invention but it does feel like it it
increases the surface area of my living
space by several orders of magnitude
there like the inn but I don't I
probably shouldn't bring this up to the
whole world but the in-betweens of the
in-between of the carpet Tufts I'm just
like what's in there I'm never gonna
know there's just no way for me to know
because it's too much surface area this
is the thing I know about lungs and
intestines that if you want to hide
things and to increase surface area that
the material of a carpet is the best way
to do it and that just means so much
more space for stuff to live on I'm not
like a germaphobe I'm not like freaked
out too much by it but like it does seem
to me an impossible substance to
actually clean I have to say I followed
a lot of what you were talking about but
I felt like the sudden unexpected
arrival of lungs and large intestines
was interesting basically your large
intestine is a is a carpet it's carpeted
it's yeah there you go so I'm gonna say
that's not a carpet
our next question comes from Adam who
writes Dear John and Hank when we
eventually discover life on another
planet but it's not what we would call
intelligent like it's microbial or
something then what how do you think
this um Adam that's good Adam that's a
great name specifics I know I didn't
even get it until you set it out loud
Adam I how what first of all that's
extremely exciting second it's probably
what will happen Rob we're not gonna be
was yeah the earth was that for like
half of the amount of time there has
been life on Earth so billions of years
it was just just microbes and it was a
stinky gross [ __ ] G slimy place full of
one celled things and and that's if I
could go back and look at Earth back
then it's like as long as I have this
long just a carpet as long as I had an
environment suit and a way to get out
yeah do it let I want to know about that
weird old life and what we know from
fossils is is a lot but it's certainly
not anything like what we would know if
we were able to examine it directly and
and and I think that we would do our
best to study it in a non-invasive way I
don't think that it would be
particularly useful and maybe it would
be maybe we'd find a way to like
dehydrate the whole thing and be like
now your fuel but probably not and what
we would the the main thing that we
would find is like unlike the other ways
in which life evolves because we won't
we kind of only have the one way that
life was created here on earth as far as
we know and to have you know a second
data point would would be infinitely
valuable and fascinating to see the
evolutionary history of another
ecosystem yeah I agree I would prefer
any alien life to be single-celled
because if it's much more complex than
just microbial life I think it will be
more complex than us and then I think
it'll treat us the way that we would
treat microbial life well here's
something to keep in mind John that the
vast majority of humans are killed by
microbes Oh believe me I am aware so so
be be worried about microbes just cuz
they're just cuz they're little and
don't think much of us and don't think
it all doesn't mean they won't kill the
heck out of our entire species not get a
chance I am very worried about microbes
yes that's my number four worry I would
say it's definitely in my top ten I
spend a lot of time worrying about
microbes they are everywhere yeah mostly
they're just fine and not doing not
doing much but I I've read a couple of
books in which humans and alien
ecosystems end up infected and it's it's
an interesting thought process because
of course like the way that microbes on
earth exist is that like they have
co-evolved with our immune systems and
so they have to figure out ways to
overcome our immune systems and most of
them can't even start to try to do that
which is why so many microbes are just
are sort of a positive part of our
bodies but on another planet there are
sort of two schools of thought one is
that like none of these microbes would
have any idea how our immune system
works and so they would not be able to
hurt us at all the other is it's so
different it's so deeply deeply
different that our immune system would
have no idea what to do and the microbe
would just consume us like food mmm
that's always been how I wanted to go
out this next question goes for
Stephanie who asked dreg and John my
name is Stephanie and I'm a student at
the University of California Santa Cruz
the dining halls of my university only
allow you to take one piece of fruit or
one dessert to go to help enforce this
policy there are signs posted which say
something to the effect of stealing food
hurts everyone is this true does taking
snacks to go impact the cost of
operations and therefore the cost of
attendance of the University I would
imagine that the answer would be yes if
the food was going to waste and being
taken in large quantities but when I
take something it's most likely because
I didn't have the time to sit and eat it
however I don't know if this is for sure
the norm banana slugs Stephanie do you
know why Stephanie signed off banana
slugs because that's the the mascot of
the University of Santa Cruz or
California at Santa Cruz that is correct
yeah they have an amazing seal for the
university I don't know this is their
official seal but it's just as UC Santa
Cruz and then there's a banana slug
reading a book and the book just says
play-doh so I assume that it's it's a
good it's a good old one I mean I assume
it's the dialogues but it's not it's not
stated outright I think that this is a
dumb rule I don't know so here's my
perspective John as with everything in
life this as with every dumb rule that I
find annoying it exists because someone
was doing the wrong thing and they knew
it so someone was taken like 80 desserts
and taken it back to their room and
hoarding them or sell it even or selling
them or doing something like finding
some way to game the system in a way
that was like fine we have to start a
rule night right right there was
somebody with like essentially an apple
store but not where they sold IMAX where
they sold actual apples out of their
dorm room they stole from the cafeteria
and then the government of the school
had to be like oh god I guess we have to
make a rule but yeah short answer
Stephanie is in my opinion as long as
you are violating the letter of this law
but not the spirit of the law I think
it's fine because the truth is you pay a
lot of money to go to college and the
reason that college is expensive is not
because of apples no I would not say
that it's the apples and I would not say
that it's whatever the desserts are and
I feel a little bit slighted that I
don't know what the desserts are I can't
really remember what we had at my
college cafeteria but I don't think that
we had good dessert
we did have fruits though and I never
ate those because that's ridiculous
who's eating fruit in college I would
estimate that I ate five hundred pounds
of Lucky Charms in college I to every
meal to fruits like two whole fruits no
I mean I didn't get scurvy because I was
eating Lucky Charms which is fortified
with vitamin C I didn't need to eat
fruit
it's virile fruits I probably had two
fruits in college I would estimate that
hey I mean I'm not a person who chooses
to eat fruits and vegetables just ever
Marta the question is do you count the
filling in the pop-tart cuz in that case
I probably had a bunch of fruits god I
ate a lot of pop-tarts in college I
recently had a puff to heart Hank and I
used to just eat them raw right I
wouldn't toast them I would just jerk
him of course
I recently had a pop tart when I was
finishing Turtles all the way down I
spent five days alone not recommended
and as part of that I didn't leave the
little building that I was in almost the
whole time and so I had to eat kind of
whatever was there and I ate a pop-tart
and it was so and I apologize if in the
future pop-tart sponsors this podcast
because I will absolutely shill for them
at the pop-tart I ate in Michigan while
I was finishing turtles all the way down
was so bad it was so bad that even
though there was no other food I was
like ah I'll wait till tomorrow to eat I
disagree with you I still have pop-tarts
oh god they're awful I mean they taste
highly processed and this is coming from
someone I like to eat food in bar form I
I almost I would be very happy to eat
exclusively bars for the rest of my life
zone bars noted dear Hank and John
sponsor rx bars which I do genuinely
love power bars there's a character in
the Douglas Coupland novel Micra serves
who at a certain point in the novel
becomes extremely stressed out and
closes his door and will only eat food
that can be slid under the door
uh-huh I would do very well only eating
food that can be slid under a door
because I love a good flat food from
garlic naan to zone bars I like a good
food I would be fine with that but
pop-tarts are disgusting Ivan I like him
maybe he didn't have a good flavor no I
had this strawberry frosted flavor the
kind that I ate all the time in college
yeah I don't know I don't love the
frosting it's it's a little bit like if
you sugar coated sugar right it seems
unnecessary to have turned it all the
way into a sweet tart but I do like the
non frosted strawberry still and we very
occasionally will buy those but in
college I bought them so regularly that
I was they and and for a year of time
there was a happy face on the side of
the pop-tart box just like our yellow
happy face and I had a whole my wall was
covered in these yellow happy faces
because like I guess I wanted to prove
[Laughter]
no I was like the level of enthusiasm I
had for Pop Tarts I love that that's
brilliant
it's like us some people in college have
huge collections of beer cans and you're
like yes that's very impressive I see
that not drunk a lot of beers but it's
for Pop Tarts while we're on this topic
you know one other thing that hasn't
held up for me that I loved in college
Taco Bell oh I I Wow I mean like I just
guess I haven't grown up cuz I gotta
talk about like once or twice a week
really yeah I mean I'm lucky if I can
eat out at all once or twice a week and
that's impressive to me I don't know
that I would call Taco Bell eating out
oh I absolutely would I mean any place
that is not my home where I eat dinner
with my children is eating out
absolutely oh I'm not like my children
my Orin is never there No
I am always by myself when I go to Taco
Bell Taco Bell is exclusively a I am
starving and on the way somewhere food
but I like it
alright I think it's great I think it's
great and that reminds me that today's
podcast is brought to you by Taco Bell
Taco Bell Hank loves it it's on the way
the podcast is also brought to you by
guarding the Mona Lisa your eyeballs are
gonna fall out of your head but at least
you got this podcast to listen to that's
true and of course today's podcast is
also brought to you by banana slugs
banana slugs the leading mascot slug in
American universities I believe probably
the probably the leading slug and this
podcast is additionally brought to you
by a fruit the one fruit that you ate
while in college we also have a real
sponsor today it's our friends at
audible you can go to audible.com slash
dear Hank or audible.com slash Dear John
or in very cool news you can just text a
500 500 500 zero five zero zero text
that number dear Hank or Dear John and
you can start a 30-day trial and get
your first audiobook free it is we love
audible I Hank and I'm doing with
audible love audible we listen to books
all the time it is an I think an
incredible way to access the world's
information while in my case you are
spreading mulch ah you know I like about
our sponsorships John is that the people
who work at these companies who have to
create these coupon codes are like okay
I guess I will make two of them we work
with Hank and John I guess that's fine
so I apologize to those people for
making you make an extra coupon code but
if you text dear Hank to 500 500 you can
get started on your 30-day trial and I I
don't know like if I go through my audio
my audible like listens I have listened
to a lot of books and I tend to use more
than just what my one credit amount
so I tend to tend to buy credits fairly
regularly and they're about $12 and you
can get God you know and most of the
audiobooks I end up buying are in the 20
to 30 dollar range and and so I you know
I am right now listening to a fairly new
book from 2017 called Jade City by Fonda
Lee it's awesome and the reading is so
good it's about it's like kung-fu plus
like 1950s gangsters so good interesting
Jade City yeah that sounds really good
that sounds very promising I'm gonna
check that out it's the first in a
series and and I had and it was
nominated for Nebula Award for Best
novel and I'm always super into that so
it's yet so it's sort of like a fantasy
fiction come foo
gangster novel that sounds pretty great
I should say that my novels Turtles all
the way down Looking for Alaska both
narrated by Kate Rudd are available at
audible you can go to audible.com slash
Dear John or audible.com slash dear Hank
and get it I have been listening to a
book I actually read in print but I
wanted to listen to the audiobook as
well it's called dear Martin by an
author named Nick stone and I loved the
book so much I thought it would be
interesting to listen to it and it has
been it's very good it's very I've
really really enjoyed it so it's I
highly recommend it yeah so that's
audible thank you audible for supporting
for supporting us and for supporting
lots of podcasts and for supporting
authors and I look like getting getting
more books into people's brains we it's
all all appreciated we also have a
project for awesome message from Rebecca
in the UK who says to all of the
wonderful people who spend their lives
trying to better educate and inform my
generation thank you I appreciate it
beyond measure Hank and John that
includes you guys without the wonderful
things you create on flog where this
crash course etc I wouldn't be anywhere
near as well informed on current events
that's great Thank You Rebecca
and and I appreciate you so much for
thinking about educators and teachers as
a young person which I did not do enough
when I was that
no God didn't either I was did not
appreciate what the gifts that were
being given to me I was so terrible to
my teachers I've expressed this regret
to them each in person except for the
ones who died before I had a chance to
but I it's like I thought that teaching
me was a privilege like aren't you lucky
that you could just spend 50 minutes
every weekday with this jackass right
yeah I mean I wish I could yeah that's
all I could say about my high school
self I'm not proud this next question
comes from Natalie who writes dear John
and Hank John at what point did you know
your novel would be translated into
different languages and did you get to
choose which languages you want your
novels to get translated into Hank well
an absolutely remarkable thing which is
available for pre-order now and comes
out September 25th be translated into
different languages will you keep the
same cover for different languages or
choose different ones I have no idea
what I can use as a name specific sign
off Natalie this is an interesting
question and it is a world I did not
know much about before I became a yeah
no I had no idea this was and even this
was all very new to me as I was doing it
I did not understand I did not
understand how this works so now I do
the first thing natalie is that I don't
get to choose what languages my book
comes out in I would like it to come out
in all the languages all of the world's
languages but many languages only you
know they only published a certain
number of books some have quite small
publishing industries and so for years
my books were published in a few
countries some of them successfully some
of the months successfully but then when
the fault in our stars came out suddenly
my book was in like 50 languages which
was incredibly exciting and I love
having all of those covers and even
though I can't read any of these books
seeing all of them and I love getting
great questions from my translators and
I have built relationships with some of
them that are more than a decade old now
so it's a really cool part of publishing
and in some ways it's my favorite part
because I also don't have to do any work
oh well you just it's I didn't even know
that you would sort of field questions
from translators to be like yes and this
this is what I kind of mean here right
like obviously like you're not gonna
translate this directly so like you're
gonna have to get at this thing somehow
right I love those conversations I also
find that my translators are such good
readers in general - I think to be a
translator you have to read so carefully
and thoughtfully it's a real it's a real
talent and the people who are brilliant
at it can in some cases I think make
your books better like I don't I don't
read German or Dutch but I know from the
reviews that my books must be better in
German and Dutch than their and the that
that different covers is also
interesting so there's different
publishing companies in different
countries and each publishing company
kinda seems to decide what the cover is
gonna be and they're like I sort of got
an email that was like the UK publisher
and would like to use the same cover as
the US publisher they'd like that cover
they want to use it and I was like that
was maybe not gonna be the thing I guess
because sometimes UK covers are
different and so that is the decision of
the publisher that they decide and the
publisher decides like always decides
what the cover is authors oftentimes get
no say over what their book cover is I
got more say than the average but like
ultimately it's not my decision right
it's certainly not your decision when it
comes to foreign language covers but
yeah it's also not really your decision
usually when it comes to English
language covers right almost all almost
all publishing contracts have it written
in that the author does not get to
decide the cover because well from the
publishers perspective authors are often
quite bad at that but also it can be a
big fight it is often a big fight in
publishing Hank and I have both been
really lucky in that I think we both
like our covers but that doesn't always
happen yeah yeah definitely not and I
haven't always I haven't always liked my
covers to be honest there's there's some
I think there's some some duds out there
but I like all of them currently and I
even the foreign covers that I don't
like I'm always fascinated by and some
of them I love the Swedish covers of my
books in fact we got so good we'll put a
couple of the Swedish covers on the
patreon at patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John the Swedish governing the
Swedish cover of turtles all the way
down might be the greatest single image
I've ever seen in my entire life I love
it I want it like if I ever get a tattoo
it's just gonna be the Swedish cover of
turtles all the way down and getting
like and the fact that you get different
covers for different editions is really
exciting to me because I like the
experience of excitement and joy I got
when I was like this is the cover of the
book I'm gonna get to have that other
times not like maybe exactly the same
because you know it will be less sort of
like the emblematic cover in my life but
I'm gonna get to experience like
basically artists creating art based on
a thing that I made which is that's
great that's one of the great feelings
and also is one of the great feelings of
being you know a internet creator when
people make fan art it's just like so
inspiring and and like humbling to be
part of other people's artistic process
yeah it's already agreed all right we
got to answer one more question before
we get to the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon big big AFC
Wimbledon news this week that I was
there to see in real life mm-hmm okay
all right last question I'm gonna do a
serious one John we got to get some
serious ones okay this one's from
Veronica I mean stop it a little bit
more my boyfriend broke up with me last
week he we had spent the better part of
a decade together and he saw me go from
an insecure high school student all the
way to a kick-ass high school teacher
Congrats Veronica I get that he doesn't
love me anymore and that there's no use
forcing anybody to be with a person they
don't want to be with however this
breakup isn't just about us his family
practically raised me they asked me to
come over for Sunday dinners when he's
not there is that weird
can i still be friends with my
ex-boyfriends family they feel like
family to me and I love them dearly also
I'm his little sister's godmother to
further complicate the matter my
relationship didn't end in death
Veronica
yeah Veronica yeah that's that's rough
man that's rough yeah that's hard yeah I
think that like so you're gonna want to
ask yourself some questions and you may
want to ask your ex some questions you
may want to ask the family some
questions I think that the the main
thing and it doesn't seem like this to
me but the main thing is like you aren't
hanging out with these people because
you're trying to rekindle the
relationship you're trying to bring it
back are you trying to like eat like
keep yourself in that person's life so
maybe they'll see you and and what like
you you do want to move on and you don't
want this to be a barrier to moving on
into other relationships and into it
like this new part of your life that's
not gonna have this person in it
romantically but it does sound like
these are people who matter a lot to you
and so as long as that's it's not about
that to you and they're not in some way
trying to like insert you you back into
your ex-boyfriends life which is a thing
that I've seen families do where they're
like he made a bad decision so we're
gonna try to make him under it as long
as they're not trying to do that and
you're not trying to do that and this is
about you maintaining relationships
external to that like how you're feeling
about your boyfriend then I think it's
okay it's just something to be conscious
of and careful with yeah I think it's
hardened I think you might find yourself
needing to take a few steps away for a
while
just to understand what the new reality
is gonna be and get used to this new
normal I remember when my longest term
relationship that wasn't with Sarah
ended what was really really unbearably
painful to me was the thought that this
family that I had really become a part
of I wasn't gonna be a part of anymore
and that was it was devastating it was
really really difficult and I still miss
I I still miss that family and and think
very highly of them and you know hold
them in my thoughts but for me I felt
like I couldn't continue that that
relationship because I didn't want to be
you know I didn't want to be in the wet
in the way of their life as a family but
it was really difficult and I think it
varies from case to case and I think
you've got a as Hank said
kind of keep in touch with yourself more
than anything and understand what your
what you're going through and and what
you need all right John
make one last thing before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon mark
wrote in with a very important
correction Dear John and Hank I was
excited to hear my part of the world
mentioned when John commented that John
Green Comm was owned by a realtor in
Southern Mississippi I decided I would
go to this website research the realtor
and appeal to him as one South
Mississippian to another I would request
that he John Green the realtor consider
relinquishing John Green Comm to it's
more appropriate owner John Green the
author I'm not sure that I'm actually
the more appropriate owner he is as much
as John Green as I am but anyway to my
surprise and chagrin John Green the
realtor is not a South Mississippian but
al got a South Tennessean come on John I
mean as somebody whose grandmother is
from Tennessee I should have known
better I should have done better
not since the the disaster of Benjamin
Harrison have I so disgraced my family I
apologize thank you mark for the
correction and thanks for listening from
South Mississippi
um well I'll have it what a disaster
John you big liar
it is so that's basically very close
Memphis is close to North Mississippi I
believe that is correct but not gonna
stake my entire future on it um it's it
appears that John Green the realtor is
representing some very nice homes oh
really
yeah this one is a you know in coal coal
your Vil Tennessee's five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars is home to four
bedrooms two baths and that is right on
the Mississippi Tennessee border Collier
MIT was well yeah yeah yeah I was close
not I mean I do have to say John that
like I like I don't want to judge John
Green by by looks oh this is a nice home
but I might think that he's probably
retiring soon oh so I might be able to
make a play like I wouldn't be surprised
if that guy might not be a realtor in
five years okay well I mean I don't know
he's alright he's got a thing called my
John Green Comm he's
he's got a lot of stuff going on in this
site I don't want to get in the way of
it it used to have an animated gif of a
shamrock slowly rotating but this
website has made some huge progress in
the 18 years that I've been tracking it
the Shamrock is still there though held
on to the sham but it's still part it's
still part of the logo so let me get to
the news from AFC Wimbledon Hank before
you get to the news from Mars the news
from AFC Wimbledon is great I went to an
AFC Wimbledon game it was so much fun
it's always so much fun to be there I
love I love that community I am so
grateful to them for including us in in
the life of their football club it was
it's always so wonderful to be there if
you go to a game and you tell anyone
around you that that you're a
nerdfighter or that you listen to our
podcast or anything like that they will
be so welcoming it's really really a
wonderful experience if you're in London
on a Saturday I really encourage you to
find a way to get to a game it's just a
really special place I was there with
ten nerdfighters in rosianna and it was
pretty tense because AFC Wimbledon are
at this point I think it's safe to say
in real danger of of being relegated
which is terrifying and it's been a
rough season and we were playing Oxford
United again a team that traditionally
we have struggled against however AFC
Wimbledon won that game two to one Lyle
Taylor the Messi for Montserrat
the greatest I would argue forward in
the history of Montserrat national team
scored a penalty and then there was a
equalizer from Oxford at right before
half-time and it looked it just looked
to me like one of those games that was
going to end up a draw but then in a
goal mouth scramble John Meads the left
back found a way to get the ball in the
back of the net and AFC Wimbledon won
that game two to one a huge huge win I
mean if we stay up I think we are going
to look back on that win and think hmm
that might have been the one that did it
because we'd be in
relegation zone if we'd lost that game
instead we are in 18th place on 41
points it's it's gonna take 52 points to
definitely stay up so that's 11 points
from our last ten games it's gonna take
maybe only 50 points to stay up if we're
lucky which would be three wins from our
last ten games so he's still very much
there's still a lot of danger let's put
it that way there's still a lot to worry
about but it certainly looks a heck of a
lot better than it did five days ago
when you when that goal was scored what
was it what was the feeling what did you
what was it like John the moment the the
second goal was scored it was a feeling
of utter joy and excitement and lots of
high-fiving and then we settled in for
15 minutes of unmitigated terror right
because right because it's not like you
scored in like minute 90 you're
desperately clinging to a right a lead
that you kind of know you sort of have
to hold on to not just for the sake of
the game but for the for a broader
season-long cause and that was very
stressful and you could really feel it
in the stadium like the energy went from
like let's roar this team on to success
too let's try to sing but they're
probably going to hear the nerves in our
voice everybody just be very quiet
yeah and cuts your beers tightly yeah
yeah every time George long would go to
take a goal kick he would sort of fake
jog toward the ball and even though I
knew he was fake jogging and I knew he
was actually walking and trying to kill
time as best he could even that I would
I still found myself saying take your
time George take your time take your
time huh that's a death that in 10-15
minutes John just of like being like be
as slow let's do some real slow soccer
well I I did at one point point out
I mean it's a small stadium so I
genuinely believe he could hear
everything I was saying I did at one
point say to him you know you haven't
gotten a yellow card for time-wasting
yet which means that in my opinion you
have not yet wasted enough time oh man
good sports to Mike very sportsmanlike
what's the news on Mars the news from MA
I mean I always feel like I I'm just
over talking about SpaceX but eeeh on
musk is saying that they will have their
bfr rocket headed to Mars by 2020 so
they'll be testing this thing they've
they've just started testing the this
giant massive
rocket and they'll be testing it in 2019
and and then they will be sending things
test missions into orbit around Mars by
2020 this is very good news for for our
bet for me it's still I would say the
outside is tough chances yeah and I
don't know what I was thinking as as a
as years continue to pass I continue to
realize I'm a dummy but they are also
looking at using this system to travel
on earth very quickly have you heard
about this yeah for the Hyperloop no no
that's a different thing
oh oh this is where you can travel from
like New York to Sydney Australia in 14
minutes yeah that thing yeah and so I
guess I guess the more the more we're
testing this the more likely that that
will be a thing I would not travel that
way I never probably but but it would at
least need to have been around and doing
the thing for us for as long as it was
before like from like the Wright
brothers to the 747 before I signed up
but I I encourage other people to enjoy
it it does seem a little bit
irresponsibly wasteful to me but hey
people fly private jets to Australia
and yeah so so it looks like you know I
must plan is to be sending a sending a
thing into Mars orbit by 2020 which it
doesn't seem that doesn't seem like out
outside of possibility considering that
he was able to launch that Tesla
Roadster out beyond the orbit of Mars
getting it to the orbit of Mars is a
much different technological challenge
like having the amount of energy
necessary to get it there as one thing
having all the technology necessary to
aim it in the right waves to basically
hit a dart that is you know hundreds of
thousands of miles away is a different
thing well you're I think you're trying
to hit a dartboard with a dart yeah you
try to know you're throwing a dart
you're trying to hit a planet or
something that doesn't seem that hard I
want to point out one thing Hank which
is that in the exact same interview
where he talked about all of this stuff
Elon Musk also said and I'm quoting him
directly historically people have told
me my time lines have been optimistic
[Laughter]
yeah so I'm not I feel really really
good about the chances that this podcast
is going to be called Dear John and Hank
within a decade
I the good news is that I will have held
on to dear Hank and John for a long time
maybe it was a really savvy move on my
part I also want to self-correct and say
that Mars is millions of miles away not
hundreds of thousands a there's also
hundreds of thousands of miles away but
more accurately would be to say millions
and while we're talking about response
to Corrections here's a response we got
dear Hank and John I think the world
being your oyster means that the world
is the place you live and are created
and formed and that turns you into a
dope pearl you are welcome says Olivia
sure so I guess I am the irritating
grain of sand in the world that the
world polishes into something that is a
little bit nicer or doesn't I mean a lot
of times doesn't become a pearl
or yeah I mean sometimes the oyster just
dies thanks you're pod with me Hank
it's been a pleasure as always what it
was learned today John well we learned
that sometimes the oyster just dies we
learned that book translation is
complicated it is the decision of a
company that is in that country not of
the author definitely not of the author
we also learned of course that Hank
still enjoys pop-tarts I do and I but
but my relationship with them is less
unhealthy now than it used to be and
finally we learned that John and Hank
green have taken it upon themselves to
force the social media marketing people
at many different companies to create
two instead of one coupon code and that
we feel a little bit bad about that
Thanks audible all right this podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
sheridan Gibson it's edited by nicholas
jenkins our head of community and
communications is victoria bon giorno
who also helps to run our patreon and is
gonna put up some excellent Swedish
covers of John's books on that patreon
that you can see whether or not you're a
patreon supporter but we do appreciate
our patreon supporters because they
allow us to make this podcast but also
that money goes to word things like
scishow and crash course and all of the
cool things that we make it complexly so
thank you so much for supporting us and
also if you support us you can get our
weekly very bad podcast this weekend
Ryan's at the five dollar podcast the
support level over at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John and yeah that's the
that's the whole thing the music that
you're hearing right now and at the
beginning of the podcast is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]
you
[Music]